la quema del pan e incluso también de
otros objetos es la antesala el inicio
del pésaj la pascua judía durante la
semana que dura esta festividad
religiosa cualquier producto que
contenga levadura está totalmente
prohibido e incluso castigado de ahí que
se proceda a la quema del hummer tal y
como ordena el segundo libro de la torá
el sustituto para el pan es el match a
una especie de galletita chata que
recuerda que durante el éxodo del pueblo
judío durante el egipto faraónico éstos
no pudieron ver como el pan se elevaba
no se sopesa el pan no es kosher durante
el pesaje
quemar el hammett es tomar todo el pan y
todo producto leudado y echarlo al fuego
mientras en casa no queda racimo
cleaning out for pesaje
warsh antes del pesah cuando dios nos
sacó de egipto nos gusta representar el
hecho de que nos deshacemos de todas las
malas influencias y que vamos a hacer
completamente devotos al servicio de
dios esto es lo que representamos con la
quema del pan o del prd
ya al atardecer el pez hasta celebra con
el ceder una comida familiar en la que
se comparten lecturas y tradiciones para
los más pequeños todo en torno a esta
liberación del pueblo judío y para ellos
es el acto fundacional del judaísmo el
pesaje también es muy particular porque
hoy coincide con el viernes tanto
cristiano y el segundo viernes del
ramadán por el cual se han desplegado
muchos más soldados y policía israelíes
sobre todo aquí en jerusalén ya la
tensión que van creciendo o se ha notado
en la mezquita de al-aqsa donde en el
interior han irrumpido fuerzas israelíes
lanzando gases lacrimógenos y balas de
goma contra un grupo que se identificó
con hamás y que tenía piedras en las
manos